it's impossible to control a man who
needs nothing when a person eliminates
desire they destroy the influence anyone
and anything has over them so if you no
longer need validation you can pursue
that new thing you can eliminate desire
in two ways you can work on your head so
that you need nothing and you eventually
become a Buddhist monk or you can
satisfy your initial desire so that you
are an individual unit you are not
incomplete you can function on your own
if you're an individual person you can
add value to the relationship but you do
not require their validation and then
you can actually pursue whatever it is
that you want rather than wondering if
you're fulfilling someone else's dream